In 1994, The Little Rascals hit theaters...but
wasn't a huge box office hit.
Instead, it became a favorite among millennials
due to frequent airings on cable TV.
It's a sweet, low-key outing, but it’s a
standout because of its cast of delightful
child actors.
So, where is the cast of The Little Rascals
now?
"Otay!"
Travis Tedford
Previously seen as a tiny pitchman for Welch's
grape juice, Travis Tedford played Spanky,
leader of the Little Rascals.
After appearing in forgettable movies like
The Thirteenth Floor, Tedford moved back to
his home state of Texas in 2002, and now works
in marketing for a large credit union.
Brandon “Bug” Hall
The actor who played the lovelorn Alfalfa
followed up The Little Rascals with appearances
in films like the aptly-titled The Stupids,
and played Eddie Munster in The Munsters Scary
Little Christmas.
Bug Hall has continued to work steadily, appearing
on Castle, CSI Miami, and Criminal Minds.
In the 2014 direct-to-DVD The Little Rascals
Save the Day, he has a cameo as an ice cream
man.
Ross Bagley
Of all of his co-stars, Ross Bagley, who played
Buckwheat, enjoyed the most high-profile acting
career.
Back when sitcoms brought in cute tykes to
boost ratings, Bagley appeared as Nicky, the
precocious little kid in The Fresh Prince
of Bel Air.
He co-starred with Will Smith once more in
Independence Day.
Bagley later took a break from acting, and
recently earned his degree in film studies.
Brittany Ashton Holmes
Darla charmed audiences as the object of Alfalfa's
affections, as well as the target of the He-Man
Woman-Haters Club.
It was Brittany Ashton Holmes' first-ever
role, and has remained her most prominent.
She retired from the screen at the ripe old
age of seven, and is pursuing a degree in
political science.
Blake McIver Ewing
Waldo was the villain of The Little Rascals,
as the son of a wealthy oil baron played by
Donald Trump.
Post-Little Rascals, Blake McIver Ewing voiced
Eugene on Hey Arnold! and hosted The People's
Couch.
He's also worked with the It Gets Better project,
and funded the recording of an album by working
as a go-go dancer.
Ewing opted to keep Waldo's amazing hair into
adulthood, which is simply awesome.
Kevin Jamal Woods
The kid who played Stymie continued acting
sporadically throughout childhood, appearing
in two distinctly '90s things: He voiced a
puppy in Babe, and guest-starred on Walker,
Texas Ranger.
These days, Kevin Jamal Woods is an audio
engineer and music producer in Texas.
Zachary Mabry
Porky stole a lot of scenes as Spanky's little
brother and devoted assistant.
It's the only acting Zachary Mabry ever did.
Now, he’s a public sector accountant in
the Dallas area.
Sam Saletta
If there're a bunch of kids getting into crazy
adventures, you need a bully to bug'em right?
That's Movie Logic 101.
Since playing Butch in The Little Rascals,
Sam Saletta has done a lot of voiceover work,
particularly for Recess, Rocket Power, and
the video game Call of Duty: Black Ops.
He's also a singer-songwriter, and played
in a band called Jubala.
Petey the Dog
Petey’s last on-screen credit comes from
a 2012 documentary series called American
Dog.
And considering that The Little Rascals was
released more than 20 years ago, it's safe
to say Petey has since been, uh, sent to a
nice farm upstate where he can run and play
all day.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
Rascal was your favorite...